the edge of 17 is directed by Kelly
Fremont Craig and stars Hailee Steinfeld
as Nadine a very angsty teenager who's
gone through a personal tragedy who
thinks that life is awful everything
sucks she hates everybody around her her
best friend starts dating her older
brother so that's that yeah that
actually that that actually does suck
that would that would suck but for the
most part she hates everything about
life she has a hard time relating to
other students and she often finds
herself sitting down with her teacher
played by Woody Harrelson just vomiting
out all of her problems to him while he
sits there thinking my god
I don't get paid enough for this the
last movie Kelly Fremont Craig made was
post grad which I thought was pretty bad
so I had no anticipation for this movie
she wrote and directed it and I got to
say this is one of the biggest surprises
of this entire year I love this movie
for this genre what this movie is an
angsty high school movie where you have
a character who's trying to traverse the
horrible hell that is high school while
dealing with everything else that comes
with life there's a whole bunch of
movies like that you got Heather's you
have Mean Girls this is definitely in
the upper echelon of those films because
of how well-written it is
I loved how this movie was rated are
these high schoolers talk vulgar they
say that high schoolers say there's
no attempt to censor or water down this
movie or make it pg-13 to get a higher
box-office return because if you
actually watch the trailer for this
movie it looks like a pg-13 type movie
the green bad one anyway but this is a
surprisingly mature film that I think is
actually more aimed at adults who have
gone through these life experiences can
look at those life experiences and go oh
I remember that and that's very true and
that's something I also really
appreciated about this movie because the
scenes and the scenarios that play out
for young Nadine get increasingly more
humiliating and awful for her but they
always feel like they're coming from a
place of truth the dialogue really bites
I mean she will often just explode on
people and say the most offensive things
you could think of to say to somebody
and then they will just come back and
say it right to her there's no attempt
to make this movie politically correct
in fact there are even words and phrases
used in the
movie that most people would be like wow
you can't say that and no one in the
movie goes don't say that word you can't
say that word that's bad
high schoolers talk the way high
schoolers talk in this movie and I
really appreciated that about this film
there's no attempt to be like hey look
here's the squeaky clean version of
today's high school it's not like that
and that's something I loved Hailee
Steinfeld was great in True Grit I
thought she was really good for such a
young actress and here though I think
she gives my favorite performance I've
seen from her her character is most
certainly a drama queen she's rude to
everyone her family her friends nobody
gets off that list
and the movie also doesn't take the easy
way out of explaining why she is that
way it doesn't just take a horrible
family tragedy and say this is why she
is this way because the film actually
shows her before that occurs as a young
girl and she was difficult to deal with
even then then the film says hey you
thought she was bad then well let's just
throw all this on her and oh my God
look what came out of that situation
there are logical reasons for her acting
this way it's not just like oh she's an
angsty teen because this is an angsty
teen movie I got to say though I think
my favorite thing about this movie and
it's specifically because I'm a guy
usually when I go to movies like this
that are written and directed by a woman
and the lead character is a woman 90% of
the time most of the male characters in
the film are all monsters who have no
depth to them who just exists to make
life living hell for all the female
characters which is a big reason I think
a lot of guys don't enjoy going to
movies like this one of the most
refreshing things about the edge of
seventeen for me as a guy is that the
male characters are also given a lot of
depth and a lot of background and you
can understand where they're coming from
they're not just little pieces on a
board to be positioned in a certain way
to make everything shitty for our main
character there's one dude in this movie
towards the end who's kind of an asshole
but even him you can understand why he's
upset and why he's doing what he's doing
because of what he was led to believe
and it's the same with the women in this
movie Nadine isn't just an angsty teen
because that's an easy route to take as
a writer her best friend who ends up
sleeping with her brother which isn't a
spoiler by the way it's in like the
first five minutes of the movie she's
not just that girl that does that
because you need a dramatic scene in a
movie she feels real - and so does her
brother you don't
look at him and go what an asshole for
doing that it's sort of just like this
really terrible situation and it's very
real I mean there are so many times in
real life where people just make
mistakes who are friends or family
members and they're not assholes for
making mistakes people just make
mistakes and sometimes happens and
this movie explores that really well and
gives it a far more mature level of
depth than I was anticipating one of my
favorite parts of this movie is Woody
Harrelson as her teacher who just says
everything a teacher should never say as
somebody who's to work in the school
system I got to say that's one of the
more unrealistic parts of the movie if
people found out what he was saying he'd
be fired instantly on the spot but it
did provide a lot of really good humor
in the movie and I loved their
conversations I suppose my biggest flaw
with this movie is that at about the
halfway point when you see every
character that's been introduced you can
instantly know where everything's going
you can look at that character and say
okay those two are going to be together
you can look at that person and be like
not not going to happen it's just you
know exactly where the film is going and
it follows those similar storytelling
cliches and tropes that you would expect
in a film like this that's my biggest
flaw with the movie but I've said this
before and I'll say it again if a film
has great characters and good dialogue
and is directed with passion I can watch
a film and understand where it's going
to go and it can have cliches but if
it's all done really well and shown
through someone's vision that feels
original and fresh I'm fine with that
the edge of seventeen is one of the
biggest surprises for me of this entire
year and I'm going to give it an A -
fantastic beasts and where to find them
is really good but don't let that huge
film bury this film go out and see this
it's worth your time guys thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuff mine eyes